new details in Harrison Wagner's cause
of death almost six months after the son
of Jack and Christina Wagner was found
dead in a parking lot in docks obtained
by ET the LA County Medical examiner's
Office says Harrison died as a result of
ingesting Two drugs a generic version of
Xanax and Fentanyl and his death has
been ruled in accident
in the wake of their son's death Jack
and Christina announced a scholarship
fund and his honor the website read in
part quote we are heartbroken that
Harrison ultimately lost his battle with
addiction and the report comes days
after a solemn milestone for Harrison's
loved ones he would have turned 28 years
old on December 1st
last week Christina shared this video of
her son looking happy and paid tribute
in the Instagram caption calling
Harrison quote Larger than Life with
quote vulnerability and compassion
underneath quote I had the privilege to
know Harrison for 27 incredible years he
understood his own defects and worked
hard to turn them around to strengthen
his positive attributes he was a good
listener and stood up for others when
they couldn't speak for themselves I
meant what I said Christina and Jack who
met while co-starring on General
Hospital divorced in 2006 after 13 years
of marriage you know she hasn't been
back to work and when she does we will
be there with open arms following
Harrison's death the soap's cast shared
with E.T how they were supporting The
Grieving parents just love them as much
as we can there's no way to lessen the
pain but just be there for them whenever
they need us she is remarkably strong
and she was an exemplary mother and
there was a very challenging it's very
challenging to have a son
that has an addiction that is a disease
and they both handle it very well but
Christina I admire her very very much
and she's doing really well under the
circumstances very strong my heart goes
out to them and it's tragic
and I hope more people are aware of the
epidemic that's going on that's been
going on for decades but really really
bad right now
and my prayers are with them the family
all the friends and everyone who
supports and lifts you up and makes you
smile Christina ended her tribute to
Harrison with a message for anyone going
through the unthinkable quote to all
bereaved parents may you find peace
let's stick around and see what's in
store for our extraordinary lives
foreign